il se passe des choses assez incroyables
dans le nom de l'ateq je vous parle
aujourd'hui de la mort du ps store ou
comment les chinois les entreprises
chinoises que sont les géants du
smartphone et notamment huawei mais pas
que huawei veulent aller en tire google
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que depuis
un certain nombre de mois et ça se
prolonge ça sent vraiment s'inscrire
dans la durée
il ya une vraie guerre entre la chine et
les us et notamment entre huawei les us
les us sont blacklistés huawei tout
simplement l'accent sur la liste noire
les gens n'ont plus aucune entreprise
américaine ne peut commercer avec huawei
huawei soupçonnées d'espionner pour le
compte de pékin de donner des
informations à la chine donc les us
donald trump ont dit stop
huawei bosquet près avec l'ancien put
beaucoup de choses et notamment celles
dont moi je vous parle aujourd'hui c'est
la problématique liée à android vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir que les
smartphones de huawei tourne sur android
et que sans licence android
ils peuvent uniquement utilisé la
version libre la version la plus simple
sans aucune application de google ce qui
veut dire que vous n'avez pas de gmail
vous n'avez pas de carte vous n'avez pas
de youtube vous n'avez pas plein de
choses ça bloque vraiment au wawel je
vous en ai effectivement parlé dans ma
vidéo de test du mec 30 rock est le
premier smartphone est sorti sans la
licence était quand même disponible lors
y avait un petit hack qui consistait à
installer le bleiz torse que je ne vous
recommande est pas parce qu on n'avait
aucune visibilité là dessus ça ne
semblait pas être extrêmement fiable je
peux pas garantir la sécurité
je peux pas vous garantir qu'ils aient
pas de backdoor pas vous garantir que
vos infos seront complètement protégé
donc je veux pas vous pousser là dessus
ce pauvre inciter à le faire et on a vu
à quel point c'était handicapant pour un
smartphone d'être utilisé en tout cas
avec les usages qu'on en a un autre que
les jeunes gens nés moi pas de gmail pas
de youtube et s'est tout de suite très
très très très compliqué autant le
smartphone est génial
autant l'utiliser sans cinq mois c'est
un petit peu un très très beau produit
une très belle finition un produit très
sympa que je trouve vraiment cool mais
que malheureusement je peux pas
forcément venir vous recommander
aujourd'hui à cause de ce problème de
plextor nouveau et c'est donc dire on va
pas cesser à battre on va sortir notre
propre os harmonie os qui allait en tout
cas plutôt alléchant mais il rencontre
une vraie problématique c'est de faire
venir des développeurs externes pourquoi
parce que les développeurs notamment les
petits développeurs à bien vous savez ça
prend beaucoup de temps pour développer
le temps c'est de l'argent et ils sont
pas sûr qu'on fasse il vraie clientèle
qu'ils soient là pour acheter leurs
applications pour utiliser pour
monétiser leurs applications donc pas
forcément un énorme engouement derrière
en tout cas ça peut être vraiment un
point
l'eau quand poway d'ailleurs moreau et
lancera fin mars a priori mars fin mars
2020 à paris son nouveau flagship que
serait le paie 40 d'ailleurs j'en ai
déjà parlé du p 40
vous avez toutes les rumeurs là qui sont
par ici vous pouvez y aller vous êtes
toutes les infos pour avoir un peu le
portrait robot de ses futurs smartphones
qui à mon avis va continuer a déchiré le
pays 30 postes déjà très très très bon
le picard ont promis il va être là il va
faire très très très mal donc abonnez
vous l'essai mais aussi un joli push
pour l'algorithme il faut laisser les
pouces atteint via la vidéo des de vue
d'être découverte donc n'hésitez pas des
pousses des bisous d'amour et puis les
commentaires voir pour me dire si vous
allez bien huawei est donc dans une
situation très délicate et les autres
constructeurs chinois se sont dit ça
peut sentir potentiellement roues si on
n'est pas accusé comme moi est de
travailler pour le compte de pékin mais
on sait pas ce qu'il peut se passer à
l'avenir en tout cas ça a vraiment
montré une fragilité et une vraie
dépendance de google je pense qu'il le
savait mais qu'il n'imaginait pas être
bloquée cette manière là ils ont donc
décidé de passer à la contre attaque
en créant le global développeurs
services alliance c'est un conglomérat
c'est un rassemblement de grands deux
géants du smartphone chinois huawei au
pot shiomi et vivo à eux seuls ils sont
vraiment énormes
il représente un marché vraiment
vraiment colossal avec plein de beau
smartphone plein de belles propositions
et dont en tout cas trois aujourd'hui
ou encore accès aux playes store sans
aucun problème que son vivo au pot et
xiaomi qu'ils ont donc décidé de créer
une plateforme pour les développeurs
d'applications c'est un équivalent du
plastoc n'est plus ni moins l'idée c'est
de se dire qu'ensemble regroupés on est
beaucoup plus fort qu'un voyou
effectivement on peut rencontrer des
difficultés avec harmonie os mais si
derrière vous mettez vous en voyez au
pot vivo et shiro mis tout de suite ça
va faire un petit peu massa présente
plus gros marché et ça peut vraiment
leur permettre de lutter de se
positionner face aux us face à google
face au ps store et forcément ça risque
de faire très très très mal au ps store
ils ont un site sur lequel il explique
bien je vous le montre dans quelques
instants je leur dis que juste là en
fait le marché disait c'est neuf pays et
plusieurs régions parmi les pays cités
il ya l'inde l'indonésie la malaisie et
la russie ils ne citent en aucun cas la
chine alors ce sont des acteurs chinois
pourquoi tout simplement parce qu'en
chine vous avez une grosse censure et
que de toute façon les indices google ne
sont pas accessibles avant d'utiliser un
vpn qui globalement reste quand même
sensiblement anecdotique donc pour
l'instant le problème et si tu peux en
chine je pense qu'ils disent ok en chine
on a chacun nos positions chacun nos
business on va pas les toucher on reste
concurrents sur le marché chinois
on reste concurrents en dehors par
contre on va se regrouper pour lutter
contre google
pour lutter contre le plextor alors on
pourrait se dire ok pourquoi pas l'inde
la malaisie l'indonésie la russie
pourquoi pas ça un sens mais pourquoi
pas l'europe
pourquoi pas les états unis directement
je pense en fait ils font la main sur
des marchés sur lesquels eux sont
présents des marchés qui sont en
développement des marchés
formé il ok on se regroupe on travaille
ses marchés on se met en place
on laisse venir le développement
d'applications ça représente un gros
bassin de population ça représente
beaucoup de monde il ya beaucoup de
monde en russie en inde en indonésie en
malaisie
ce qui fait que lorsque ils ont réussi à
avoir beaucoup développeurs y avoir un
vrai modèle économique qui marche
ils pourront s'attaquer facilement à
l'europe et pourquoi pas après aux us on
les en hockey il ya aucun problème
on est là on est fort pour que les us
vous toujours être un peu prudent par
rapport à ce qui pourrait
potentiellement arriver mais pourquoi
pas en tout cas en me disant ok
regardez notre modèle économique qui
marche regardez les développeurs qui
sont positionnées dans ces pays là dans
ces neuf pays là il fonctionne
merveilleusement bien et font du
business
donc maintenant vous pouvez venir avec
nous notre modèle économique marche va
pouvoir développer en europe dans le
reste du monde
et là on va attaquer en frontal le
pstore l'ordre attaqué en frontal google
pourquoi pas sur son propre territoire
et la honda les anéantir vous pouvez
regarder sans leur site c'est vraiment
criant de vérité lors site est
disponible
ils paraissent en tout cas assez jeune
mais il montre le bien réellement ce que
c'est gds a global développeurs services
alliance
vous avez les dernières jours
applications pour l'app l'aude et mettre
à jour voyant un petit peu comment ça
fonctionne ça s'inscrit en un petit
about pour vous expliquer qu'ils sont on
va bien les pays inde indonésie russie
malaisie vous avez des emails pour les
contacter ils nous mettent au pot vivo
chez tommy on voit pas paraître huawei
là dessus c'est surprenant d'ailleurs
les petites mises à jour en neuf dates
les éleveurs ça veut donc dire qu'il y
aura des événements qui seront organisés
très probablement pour fédérer un petit
peu tout ce beau monde alors ça risque
de devenir tout ça je pense qu'il va y
avoir des choses qui arrivent mais pour
l'instant c'est vraiment vraiment le
début contact support c'est vraiment le
début mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
est ce que ça montre c'est que ça c'est
une vraie arme de guerre contre apple
store vous en ai déjà parlé dans la
vidéo quand on avait appris
effectivement que les états unis avaient
banni huawei du territoire américain
devant vous ne pouvez plus travailler
avec google vous n'avez pas là les gens
son droid vous ne pouvez plus du coup
utiliser le plextor ça me paraissait
évident que cette entreprise en tout cas
où que beaucoup d'autres entreprises
allaient prendre des positions pour
venir se protéger contre les us et
contre les problèmes qui pourraient
potentiellement leur arrivée avec un
bannissement et un blocage du pasteur
qui se passe aujourd'hui ça peut aussi
fragiliser google parce que google a la
mainmise sur les os au niveau des
smartphones et au niveau des tablettes
si demain
autres entreprises se sentent en tout
cas potentiellement en danger elles
peuvent eux déjà toutes les entreprises
chinoises pourquoi pas se regrouper en
faisant elles mêmes leur propre os ou
alors chaque marque
chaque entreprise fait son propre os on
peut imaginer il ya bien un os sur apple
il pourrait y avoir un webos pourrait y
avoir un au poète de la même manière
qu'elle est sur couche on pourra voir
des os clairement et simplement
fabriqués par les marques comme on a dit
google l'avait vu venir aussi les ont
essayé d'intervenir auprès des usa
faisant bon écoutez vous êtes bien
rigolo vous êtes bien sympa ya peut-être
un problème effectivement on sait pas
réellement parce que pour l'instant rien
n'était sorti sans tapis raison voilà ce
qu'a fait ouais voilà les preuves sont
là irréfutables et auquel cas c'est
justifié c'est clair et c'est net pour
l'instant rien n'est réellement sorti
mais par contre les conséquences
derrière sont relativement délétère et
elles le seront à mon avis pour google à
moyen long terme parce que si on regarde
la liste regardez j'ai pris le titre
fuck pu noter là dessus si on regarde la
liste des plus gros vendeur de
smartphones dans le monde
alors vous avez au début un trio de tête
avec samsung samsung qui est coréen qui
utilisent android et qui n'est
absolument pas dans le viseur là dessus
des états unis donc absolument aucun
problème
vous avez huawei warwick et chinois et
qui du coup basculerait sur cet os là à
plus ou moins long terme donc ça va pas
se faire cette année là j'imagine que ça
se fera peut-être d'ici un an un an et
demi le temps que tout s'organise mais
ça commence en tout cas à se mettre en
marche
il ya apple effectivement avec ayo est
une entreprise américaine donc il n'a
absolument aucun problème là dessus il
ya shinobi schumi qui est chinois qui
est aussi un très gros vendeur de
smartphones il ya au pot il ya vivons et
après si on va regarder même un petit
peu plus loin où un de plus au pot vivo
et remy pour partie d'un seul et même
grands groupes qui s'appelle bdk
electronics alors chacun ont leur propre
stratégie et leur propre fonctionnement
d'un moment il faut pas bêtes ils ont
des intérêts comment il voit très bien
que si ces quatre grosses entreprises
que son chien au me why au pot et vivo
se regroupent ça paraîtrait logique
copovi vos one + rnb travaillent
ensemble pour effectivement utilisé ce
magasin d'applications de plextor à la
chinoise ça me paraît très relativement
logique alors après est ce que ce serait
juste un pelé store à la chinoise est ce
que ce serait un concurrent direct
d'android pourquoi pas ça peut
réellement aussi avoir un sens
ce qui est sûr c'est que si le pari est
gagné pour la global développeurs
service avec ce sale affaire
google parce que si beaucoup
d'utilisateurs dans le monde entier
switch duplex tort alors magasin
d'applications à eux s'ils switch pourra
pas donne android à leur propre os a
également une fille née à moyen long
terme c'est ce qui devrait arriver ce
qui paraîtrait en tout cas logique qui
arrive ça pourrait faire beaucoup de mal
à google qui monétise ses services qui
pourraient pas partir beaucoup
d'utilisateurs beaucoup d'argent pas
tous derrière et la monétisation je sais
pas vous mais moi je te lis par exemple
google photos je paye un petit
abonnement pour avoir mon stockage de
photos
tout ça pourrait partir alors ça va pas
le faire tout de suite ça pas se faire
immédiatement j'imagine pas
effectivement que tous les utilisateurs
vont quitter google pour aller sur un
service qui pour l'instant n'existe pas
encore mais souvenez vous si vous
regardez un petit peu plus en arrière si
vous remontez jusqu'au début des années
2000 2005
est ce que vous vous souvenez de votre
email @ aol @ caramail
@ lycos de tous ces services qui
aujourd'hui ont disparu et qui pourtant
à l'époque nous paraissait indétrônable
on sait que sur le web
tout va très vite non ça paraît pas
déconner que google puisse perdre de sa
superbe au profit d'un nouveau service
chinois alors après effectivement il
faut rassurer les populations les ondes
on est chinois on ne va pas venir un
pirate et vos données on doit pas venir
utiliser vos données aux services d'un
quelconque état et reste quand même
beaucoup de travail à faire beaucoup a
rassuré mais ça me manque vraiment
quelque chose
ça montre vraiment un chemin et elle est
vraiment savoir qu'ils vont être les
grands gagnants et les grands perdants
de l'histoire
sur ce je vous invite à me dire vous ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
est ce que vous pensez vraiment que
cette alternative si tous ces géants
chinois arrivent vraiment bien se
regrouper correctement proposant un
service de qualité pour commencera
effectivement par l'asie par la russie
ensuite en arrivant sur l'europe et
pourquoi pas jusqu aux us
parce que vous pensez qu'ils peuvent
détrôner google en tout cas une partie
google parce que google ça reste et
nantes la maison-mère alphabet au dessus
est vraiment énorme mais il peut se
passer des choses donc s'en va
surveiller de très près 20 bidons une
fois de plus à vous abonner pour tout
savoir je vous fais des grands bisous
donne rendez vous dès demain pour
continuer à parler tech ou des bisous et
à demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]